hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to fish for the game where
you literally go underwater and murder a
bunch of fish as far as I know and I
know what you're thinking this might
just be the best game you've ever heard
of and me too so okay let's all admit
I've played stranger games in this so
let's stuff through this one might be
surprising let's go for it maybe I don't
know
Oh know what to expect I pretty much saw
from the screenshots hellooo yep
it's pretty much confirms all my
suspicions I am underwater my mouse is
very sensitive just like me and I'm
assuming I'm about to be attacked by a
bunch of murderous fish hello who I even
have a score what am I gonna do Who am I
gonna stab hello whoa whoa whoa okay
okay okay okay you need to calm down
stop messing with my boat God you try to
surround me alrighty then that started
off a little more extreme than I was
expecting
all right by boat well why are you all
red and why do you all have demon eyes
what did I just pass on the ground over
there can you die please I seem to
understand why I'm Donnie I need to
purge the world of you creepy creatures
are you even normal fish
why are you red are you feeling heel
okay let's see how many fish buns I can
do before the end of this game well well
well
more sea lambs to the slaughter well
we're all having a whale of time where's
your car now totally school in these
scrubs this game is fantastic I'm
totally hooked on it there's going
swimmingly I'm killing just for the
halibut Oh your performance is
floundering a bit my friends but this
game is really good I'd put it right
next to sturgeon simulator officially my
favorite game I uh I think I reached a
new low in my career well let's clean up
this and take off our role as the
eco-terrorists we realize hey wait a
minute
you could probably some endangered
species of very disturbing red-eyed fish
or not red-eyed but you know what I mean
they're pretty much demonic from another
world I can assume
oh just a few more laughs I must purify
this world are you all who's wait
a minute oh I'm almost done
wait a minute ready by me Oh what is
that not healthkit thank you
I need that okay there we go whoa you're
fast yeah well down Wow I'm well I
really don't know what to say about that
game mother than it was filled with that
screw it here's a video me dancing with
some fish
you